oh you know private gig I thought I had
a private gig I'd say how I went no okay
it was probably seven table for us 100
of the top lawyers in the country all
their whole in the world in the world
they're hilarious yeah I'm never doing
I'm not doing corporate gigs anymore you
are I'm gonna shut your mouth and go
there with a smile and well I can
checkered shirt a wall I guess gay
sailor I don't tell jokes I had I was in
a suit first mistake oh you did comedy
ensue I did a big mistake who told you
do that in loafers why did you do the
bolt to do that by who by the you never
tells you what company that hired me not
only that there were certain things that
I needed I know the guy who put it on
great guy and a listener of the show
great guy he was awesome but loved it
would see the one who gave you that his
son and he ran a camera his name may be
Michael but Michael didn't give you the
advice to wear a suit and loafers no -
Michael mine was very cool but out of
respect because it was black tie it
suggested your comic I know that now
dirty what that was also emceeing I know
I told some jokes I give the award first
award tall woman taller than me
stern-looking looks at me and says you
were very offensive I said what part she
said the whole thing gross and offensive
and her friend said you have a long way
to go and I went I was thank you very
much
Wow and that's how it started after
doing ten minutes of comedy and nobody
laughed for my ten minutes oh my I mean
crickets have you ever seen that happen
to me I have that happen to me and
there's whole bonds never Greg and ever
crickets and part of us just the venue
part of its I didn't feel comfortable
because it's a corporate gig they don't
get Byfleet uncomfortable situations you
still make people laugh at your gift yes
I do
they were lawyers and they were all
partners and I think some of them didn't
want to laugh at some of the risque
stuff I was saying it wasn't dirty it
was just it was just you know it was
funny and crushes and only he thought
was better the tebow charity event where
there's dying kids in the back and these
dirty jokes or this one by far better oh
wow can you believe that because that
was a bad
that was tough Wow yeah I just can't do
those this is my thing be why do it
you're not strapped for cash yeah why
why you'd all down your I learned I
learned I'm not gonna do it anymore cuz
I'm compromising myself animation yeah
about myself yeah yeah it doesn't any
feel like I'll never know I've never
done a corporate gig where I felt
comfortable I feel
I'm doing it for the money I'm working
for the man I'm working for a
corporation that's not that's not really
your but it doesn't compromise that
doesn't work with comedy the reason comp
comics are no mats are you gonna do what
you like what you want to say if you
like it you buy a ticket to the show if
not all right but this is the cup of
crank but now the corporates going hey
Brian we like you so we're gonna bring
in but we're bringing it under these
conditions yes wear a suit wear these
loafers and don't do this material do
this material well that's not can't do
that go go get someone else right
there's two other guys who are great at
yes there are they're not our friends
but they're great at that that's also
not funny
they're great at that that's not you I
know and you're not struggling on some
new comic you struggling for money I
know so do me a favor don't take a
seven-hour flight in a [ __ ] suit and
loafers we're not gonna laugh at your
comedy for a paycheck yeah that's a
bummer I know it was they paid me a
million dollars so that's that's a hard
- okay well now I'm on board I know you
don't want to do unplug to find the kid
one night with chin if you guys ever
know and then you and I do a dance
behind it huh in black silhouette ah is
really here know we're Cowboys no no no
no I'll be no we'll be dressed as
Cowboys in the back I'll play the
cowbell yeah play see I think that'd be
a distraction for chili that would be
freaking awesome yeah after the whole
song it's too much it'd be too much for
three minutes
but that's a really good move when you
do interpretive dance cover your own
face and then me and then I'm holding a
little spinning
yeah he's flying yes yes here and then
you're not wearing pant and then we both
end on just chin we're just yep
and I tie I tie your three-piece set
really tight at the base or like I'm a
bull yeah I Riley wrap it and just you
see [ __ ] yeah if you see just your balls
or you're writing it balls that's the
[ __ ] move what you I'm a boy I'm a
buck yeah take my three-piece set and
cinch it up behind you look so yeah sure
thinking right out however you want to
do it Ernie innings you but you're
writing your have you seen you bet I'm
trying to gallop you off yeah yeah yeah
yeah I got a riding crop and I'm
whipping them yes out of your whole ass
and you're so red
yes I'm whipping you stupid ass and
again I know I'm gonna take a rope I'm
gonna wrap it around the base your dong
yes okay fan out now you're and we're
gonna wrap it until I reach a battle run
so your till your balls in your the end
of your dong we're only showing in there
horrible they're they're being spraying
hole see they're being strangled I
yanked that right up and I go behind
right between your eyes and it's sitting
in your cracker-ass yes you're on your
hands and knees and I got a new [ __ ] no
I'm not doing that I got the rope over
my shoulder as I'm riding you and I'm
like let's go you [ __ ] donkey but you
got a red plaid shirt on
it's like button with my psoriasis
ablaze and I'm just a red spot a leopard
mount Loretto it's called red spotted
leopard boy in the balls
nope I'm out it's called red spotted
leopard boy and not and the donkey and
the cinched up donkey know you gotta be
in flawed outlaw come on you [ __ ]
donkey why you got to ruin the moment
for kids and he's singing that's good a
bond card that's that's that's good
modern art that's interpretive art right
I don't pass out oh you're gonna pass
out cinch up my balls that pain is gonna
be terrible and you pass out yep oh no
you fired it - and then chin to hold act
is [ __ ]
yep no I think it's better if we're in
the back just as Cowboys playing cowbell
and you're on the harmonica alright
you're crooked teeth we're [ __ ]
Invisalign I forgot
today things things hey tell me the
truth did they offer you one on one with
two and then he came out with those
teeth and they turned it down
they pulled the wrong yeah I [ __ ] do
it man I knew it was gonna catch up with
you eventually I did they're like well
do you even know the movie jackass you
know the guys from jackass yeah [ __ ]
yeah you do knoxville bam margera boys
sees almost - I'm friends with Stevo so
one of those show Brian yeah he's been
on the show one of the guys from jackass
you know died a guy named Ryan Dunn it
was a car accident
yeah he was haulin ass gt3 something
like a nice car
anyways Hulk Hogan tweeted what the
wrong person in the tweet so he goes
damn BAM I wish you were still with us
I sure would love to hang out again my
brother I love you miss you
hey and it's a screenshot from this
hello [ __ ] hilarious
God did this on Monday it's a mistake
with a bachelor that's how you fixed it
what God got ridin Banamex up sorry bad
well okay I'm talking to my buddy Jerry
Patton he goes he goes hey I go hey goes
he calls me which he's never does like
it what time he goes Jimmy's mom died
this morning I go Jimmy Burke oh yeah
[ __ ] oh I called Jimmy I leave a message
like I'm I'm choked up I love his mother
I know his mother really well known for
like you know I'm trying not to cry I'm
like Bubba I'm so sorry about your
mother
she's such a beautiful person I can't
believe she died I don't understand she
was so healthy call me I'm here for you
I'm coming down to see you I call like
hi Brian hello this is Jimmy's mom from
have I'm calling you to tell you thank
you for being so sad am i he was [ __ ]
his mom and he's going ah haha it was
Timmy
it wasn't Jesse no my boy Timmy to his
moms [ __ ] [ __ ] foot in the Hulk
Hogan come on bro God come on brother
you got to take it back here to take
back what you just said now you have a
chicken neck say I had a bird neck you
didn't say I take him back but now that
you said a chicken neck you need to take
back the fact that you said I have a
bird neck and a chicken neck and I'll
take
and I'm not gonna I'm not gonna raise my
voice while you take it back because
never neck like a kiwi bird need you to
take that back to you no I need you to
do on the spot guess what
shut your [ __ ] mouth you shut your me
and my boy hearing me talking about some
serious stuff Chris is my boy to think
it looks more like a stack of Dimes his
neck hey dude how do you think Chris uh
yeah I could see that I've seen old
pennies I know we get a roll of pennies
guys babe I was a wrestler net this
doesn't bother me because I actually
have a thick neck I've only tried in
pageants as fighters count yeah I
haven't well no cuz my neck is expansive
its athletic crazy my brother wants to
train with you we got to get him down
here you know let's do it but he'll be
here the whole month of July
really yeah let's get together yeah we
welcome to me guys some drugs I want to
get him out no no you're too skinny
Chris let me hear it if we're gonna do
something funny we'll call you but all
right I think we're gonna be manly [ __ ]
you know dude I told you I always tell
that story wouldn't you and Tim Tebow
walked in on me dead lifting 145 and I
stopped I was embarrassed I was looking
at skinny mother she bows I got
embarrassed dude